a lot of people will tell you oh
just think positive or meh try not to
worry
it sounds simple but it's not easy and
the reason why it's not easy is because
it doesn't work
and actually research shows that when
you try to ignore your worries it can
actually make them worse
look i understand this topic more than
most people because i struggled for
decades not only with worrying
and self-doubt i actually suffered from
anxiety and panic attacks for almost 25
years and in fact i took zoloft for two
decades to control my anxiety
using the five-second rule i've not only
been able to stop worrying and doubting
myself i've cured myself of anxiety and
i've been off meds for more than four
years i'm panic attack free and i almost
never ever worrying about anything and
you can teach yourself to do the exact
same thing using the rule
first here's what i want you to know
you're not a worrier
a lot of us call ourselves a worrier
right oh i'm a warrior you're not a
worrier you have a habit of worrying
that's a very big difference
you've allowed your mind to drift and
linger on negative thoughts so many
times it's now a pattern of behavior
that you repeat and you don't even
realize it and that's actually good news
because that means that you and i can
use the science of habits to break the
habit of worrying and the habit of
doubting yourself
in the language of habit research the
five-second rule is what psychologists
call a starting ritual
it's it's a tool that you can use that
will interrupt the negative thought
patterns that are encoded in your brain
as habits
and trigger positive new thought and
behavior patterns
the five second rule is shockingly
effective because it works with all the
latest research about habits what i've
learned using the five-second rule is
that i do in fact have control over what
i think and when you use the five-second
rule you'll discover that you do too
here's how you're going to use the rule
the moment
the moment that you feel your thoughts
drift and you ever noticed how worrying
and self-doubt they have a way of
literally like
taking you away from a situation you can
feel your mind go from the present
moment to drifting to something negative
maybe you're sitting at a meeting at
work and
suddenly you start talking down at
yourself and doubting yourself it
happens like that but the moment that
you catch yourself do it that's a moment
of tremendous power you have a decision
to make you can either sit there and
listen to the worry and listen to the
self-doubt and let it hijack you
or
you can make a decision to assert
control
that's when you use the rule you're
going to use the countdown trick 54321
it's essential
counting backwards interrupts the
negative thought pattern it's also going
to awaken your prefrontal cortex which
is the part of the brain that you need
to override a bad habit and replace your
bad habit with a positive new one so
every time you feel your thoughts drift
to something negative or you find
yourself worrying about things you can't
control
54321 it'll switch the gears in your
brain it'll interrupt the negative
thought pattern it'll activate your
prefrontal cortex and you've just
created a starting ritual
that will prime your mind to accept a
more positive thought
that is how you use the rule to change
some days you might use the rule 20
times to interrupt your habit of
worrying and doubting yourself
and over time when you use the rule the
worries are going to quiet so much that
you're going to find that your inner
voice really starts to shine just like
it did for kara as she wrote i've
noticed that all the time she spends
explaining herself it creates so much
noise that it drowns out her inner voice
and i'm so over it it's been a great
wake-up call to take time each day to be
still listen and know
oh and by the way
your five second rule book also comes
with 31 video mentoring sessions to
deepen your mastery of the rule for
lasting results now these mentoring
sessions will be delivered to your email
inbox for free and information on how to
get these videos is on the very last
page of the book
and to learn more about the five-second
rule and other research-backed
strategies to help you live your best
life there's a ton of free resources at
melrons.com
if you ever have the instinct to reach
out please use the five second rule and
make yourself do it
just tag me on social media using the
hashtag five second rule or shoot me an
email at hello mel robbins.com
i love
hearing from you now give us a few days
to get back in touch with you but we
will absolutely respond if you take the
time to trust your instincts and reach
out look
it takes five seconds to change your
life
so the next time you feel yourself
hesitate or your instincts come alive
that's the moment to stop thinking
five four three two one
and start living wanna be happy build a
life not just a business hey it's evan
carmichael and this channel was created
to help you overcome the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you've got
so much more inside you you've got
michael jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn the 10 habits that are
hard to develop but will pay off enjoy
habit number two feed your mind with
tony robbins if you really feed your
mind every day feed and strengthen your
mind with a 30 minute practice and by
the way i started out reading all the
time
but then i realized i was in my car all
the time in those days
i was like i'm going to turn this to a
university on wheels and i'm old that i
remember cassette tapes and probably
most of you don't even know what the
hell i'm talking about not real the real
cassette tapes you know we didn't have
where you could put 10 000 songs in your
phone or go to youtube and have a
million different videos you can watch
over and over again and the value for me
on that quite honestly was that i had to
pay for this stuff so i had to value it
and really use it like when you part
with a certain amount of money and in
those days you know six cassettes six
one hour cassettes and a couple of
workbooks was like 300 it was like the
standard offer and i remember i went
down this place called night education
night like with a sword you know and a
shield k and ight and it was this jewish
man beautiful man named mario that i
became friends with i was a little 17
year old kid my little pot belly i was
fattened and i drove all the way down
downtown l.a be about in those days like
an hour and 20 minute drive and my
little old volkswagen with no reverse
park on the hill so it wouldn't yes i
could get out
and
and i got to be friends with this man
and he had collected this how old it was
all these albums of some of the great
motivational speakers and psychologists
and psychiatrists and business people
and then gradually those things got to
actually the cassette tapes and so yeah
all these things i'd say like what's
what's the most valuable thing he said
well what do you want to work on i said
well my body and my emotions and my mind
and my spirit he was like you want
everything and he said okay let's start
with this one
and i take 300
i was making 40 a week as a janitor so
this is literally the money i'd saved
and i'd absorb it and i'd be like i
can't afford this and i'd like well i
can't afford not to
because unless i get these answers i'll
still not be able to pay my basic bills
i'll still be struggling so i was one of
the smart things i invested in myself
and so i go down and because i invested
300 in six tapes i remember jim rohn
said repetition is the mother of skill
here's something once and you kind of
understand it here again you kind of
feel heard enough he said listen to
stuff every day
until pretty soon the things i was
hearing in my head were these new
thoughts from brilliant people instead
of the old thoughts that were basically
whatever i'd been around before and it
changed my life it started to shift me
because i fed my mind habit number three
master self-control with thomas frank
this is a mindset shift that i found
more helpful than any other
self-improvement technique i've tried in
recent memory
[Music]
to put it simply when you're trying to
change your behavior forget about the
goal you're trying to achieve the
external outcome and instead focus on
the change in identity you want to
happen this is a concept that i first
read about in james clare's book atomic
habits which i highly recommend by the
way and there's this passage near the
beginning of the book that really
encapsulates it well so i'm just going
to read it to you here imagine two
people resisting a cigarette when
offered a smoke the first person says no
thanks i'm trying to quit it sounds like
a reasonable response but this person
still believes they are a smoker who is
trying to be something else they are
hoping that their behavior will change
while carrying around the same beliefs
the second person declines by saying no
thanks i'm not a smoker it's a small
difference but this statement signals a
shift in identity smoking was a part of
their former life not their current one
they no longer identify as someone who
smokes so the general idea here is that
once you've embraced a change in your
identity you're gonna find yourself
acting in alignment with that change and
if you're wondering why exactly this
happens the third chapter of robert
childe's book influenced the psychology
of persuasion has a great explanation
for it essentially humans feel this
natural compulsion to act consistently
with their past decisions as he writes
in the book once we have made a choice
or taken a stand we will encounter
personal and interpersonal pressures to
behave consistently with that commitment
those pressures will cause us to respond
in ways that justify our earlier
decision and shifting my mindset in this
way has been incredibly helpful in the
past couple of months the first way that
i implemented it was by starting to
think of myself as an athlete now i've
always been a pretty active person and
i've had a laundry list of athletic
goals on my website for quite a long
time now but i never really took the
leap and started thinking of myself as
an athlete and there was some imposter
syndrome reasons for this but after
reading that passage in the book i
decided to take the leap and start
thinking of myself as an athlete not
just as somebody who does active things
and that shift in mindset has done
wonders for my levels of self-discipline
in many different areas from going to
the gym more consistently to training
harder while i'm there to even improving
my diet which has been a lot better than
it used to be over the past couple of
months so seriously if you take nothing
else from this video i'm putting this
first for a reason start thinking about
behavior change in terms of the identity
that you want to embody rather than the
goals that you want to achieve
all right strategy number two is to
frequently remind yourself of why you're
being disciplined in the first place at
the end of the day we have to have a
strong why for our actions if we want to
do them consistently and every time i
think about this concept i'm reminded of
a story about the actor jim carrey and
it goes like this after he had arrived
in hollywood and he was still kind of an
impoverished actor one day he took out a
napkin and he drew himself a check made
out to himself for 10 million dollars
and post dated for 10 years in the
future and then he put that check in his
wallet so that every time he'd bring out
his wallet he could see it and remind
himself of why he was working so hard
what he was working towards and this is
something that you might find very
helpful to do as well try writing down
your goal or the identity you want to
assume and put it maybe on a sticky note
next to your desk or by your computer so
you can see it every single day and know
that this is why i'm building my
self-discipline this is the reason for
all the work i'm putting in
all right strategy number three is to
find ways to embrace discomfort and
embrace the resistance you feel towards
doing something that takes hard work or
that's unpleasant just like going to an
actual gym and lifting weights makes you
better at lifting weights in the future
and able to lift more weight the next
time you go in every time you embrace
discomfort you are essentially doing a
rep of the exercise that is
self-discipline because it is a skill
that can be learned it is a muscle that
can be built over time this is why i'm
such a proponent of taking cold showers
because a cold shower is something that
most people don't want to do it's not
very comfortable standing underneath
that stream of ice cold water and that's
the point every morning that you get
into the shower and you choose to turn
that handle to cold instead of hot you
are embracing discomfort you're leaning
into the resistance and that makes you
better at doing so in the future
regardless of what the task is so as you
go through your daily life find ways to
embrace discomfort it could be cold
showers it could be setting up for a 6
am rotc fitness class it could be taking
the stairs instead of the elevator
basically whatever your brain throws up
that i don't feel like an excuse that is
an opportunity to build that
self-discipline muscle and you should
take it
okay we are on to item number four of
our list which is to target the
fundamentals first and by the
fundamentals i mean the biological
necessities of life your sleep your
nutrition and your exercise habits these
are all crucial to pay attention to
because the part of your brain that
handles executive functioning the part
that regulates your desires and your
impulses requires a lot of energy and
regular rest to function at peak levels
always remember that you are first and
foremost a collection of biological
systems all of which require the right
inputs if you want to get the best
outputs out of them and i know it's easy
to picture the brain as separate from
all of this as existing in this
metaphysical realm but the only needed
fuel sources are motivation
determination and wholesome memes but
the brain needs rest it needs exercise
and it needs the right balance of
nutrients just as the rest of your body
does so if you're sleep deprived which
judging from the amount of views on this
video you probably are or you haven't
gotten enough exercise regularly or your
diet is crap that is where you should
focus your discipline first
that brings us to our fifth item on the
list and it pains me to say this one
because i personally hate doing it but
you may want to try meditation and the
reason you might want to do this is that
meditation has been shown scientifically
to help people improve their levels of
self-discipline in fact the 2013 study
at stanford university showed that
people who went through compassion
training which was a specific meditation
program were better able to regulate
their emotions afterwards and this is
crucial for remaining disciplined and
being able to make rational decisions
now an easy way to get started would be
by using guided meditation which you can
use through apps like headspace and calm
or through many free videos here on
youtube but the form of meditation that
i've always practiced which i think is
better for the development of
self-discipline specifically is a form
of what's called zazen meditation where
i simply sit and concentrate on my
breath with my eyes closed and when my
attention is inevitably pulled away by a
random thought i work to notice that and
let that thought go and then bring my
attention back to my breath and doing
this over the long term has helped with
both self-discipline and concentration
and like i said i'm not a huge fan of
meditation it's probably the
self-development practice that i hate
doing the most but the benefits of doing
so are undeniable
and that brings us to our final item on
the list which is to practice building
new habits now like i said earlier
building new habits is kind of a
separate discipline in the overall
pursuit of changing your behavior but
the initial stages of building a new
habit often require self-discipline
because the behavior isn't automatic yet
so this can be a great way to not only
establish a new habit but become more
disciplined in the process now i've got
an entire video on building new habits
coming up for you guys in the next
couple of weeks but until then remember
that for whatever habit you choose to
build start small track your progress
maybe use an app like habitica or
strides which is my current favorite one
or habitable on android celebrate your
wins and also remember to not focus too
much on purity on perfect streaks
instead focus on making sure that your
trend is going in an overall positive
direction and remember that as it is
doing that and as that behavior is
becoming more automatic your
self-discipline is improving in the
process habit number four create battle
plans with brendan burchard is there
somewhere can you show me on a wall
visually in your house not on your
computer not in your little phone you
know not on this one little note that
you tuck away and you hide from
everybody else so they don't see what
you're working on
no show me a wall
with your battle plan
see so many people
don't break through
and they don't break through because
what's end up happening for them is so
often they're in this place where you
know unfortunately the the truth is
the truth is they didn't have a plan and
they won't talk about it and they won't
say anything to anybody and yet
if you get down to it you start coaching
you start working with them you find out
they didn't have a plan
they did not have a plan
and so
i think it's important that you realize
the value
of having
your battle plan right so a battle board
what's a battle board if i showed you
your house you would have a wall
somewhere maybe it's a you know maybe
you wrote it on a regular eight and a
half by eleven or if you saw it in my
room it's like i went to i literally got
like butcher paper
and i take you know some blue tape
and i scrapped this thing
no i strapped this thing
on this butcher tape across the wall and
what is on that wall there's 12 boxes on
that wall ladies and gentlemen what's on
that battle board 12 boxes what's each
box yep a month each box represents one
month and within that box what do i have
written down
the goals that have to happen that month
the metrics that have to happen that
month the steps i'm going to take that
month the key activities of that month
right there on the battle board
y'all got it
so and i've seen a lot of these from
clients before i'll walk in and there's
their battle board you know
they might have a fancy one made out of
burlap and tacks and beautiful instagram
ready battle board and here's what they
got they got their mission statement
across the top
and then they've got on there a reminder
of the three words of who they want to
be as a person you know enthusiastic
bold present
oh i like that then they've got the 12
boxes oh look in july here's the numbers
they're trying to hit here's what
they're trying to do in august here's
what they're trying to do in september
and on that battle board it might be the
most simple things it might be in
september
event coming up okay what are they doing
before the event here's the five steps
okay october what are they doing they're
taking the vacation here's what's going
on
but
visually
representing your battle plan
that's on a wall that you see all the
time
is so important
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
habit number five is be organized with
brian tracy the key to staying organized
is taking complete control and ownership
of your life you have to decide that you
are solely responsible for both your
actions and the outcomes of those
actions and will no longer allow any
outside forces to distract you from
achieving your goals
one of the easiest ways to accomplish
this is to have a plan of action that
keeps you on track
keep a journal or notebook to write down
your detailed plan of action
you should refer to it often keeping it
at the top of your mind on a daily basis
write out your big goal and then list
out all the detailed steps you will need
to complete to attain that goal
then break each of these steps into
smaller actions and give each action a
specified timeline
as you complete each action check it off
use this as a guide to keep you on track
in addition to your plan of action take
stock of your calendar and honestly
review how you currently spend your time
eliminate any tasks or activities that
take up time but do not move you closer
to successfully achieving your goals
happy number six start taking action
with grant cardone what you become is
what you will be
most people are sitting in a student
chair too long you're learning you like
learning studying reading you know
trying to get information dude the way
to the way to trick the system is to
become something as fast as possible
don't keep learning
buy something this is the easiest
simplest way for somebody to become an
investor
i did the deal i bought the deal with my
money did the research with my money my
time my energy in my 30 years
i use my cred
with the banks and the real estate
community to get the deal
that deals 260 million dollars
your entire audience could not buy that
deal by itself even if it had the money
because it doesn't have the connection
yep
so i'm paying i'm buying the deal with
my money and my bank my my debt
then once i buy it and close it i've
taken all this risk out
because once i buy it and close it then
i offer it up to my audience to say same
price that i pay you can get in at 1 000
5000 10 000 whatever number you're
comfortable with
so what happens is one your money's
protected against inflation and
deflation okay against the disruption
and destruction of the dollar which is
what what's happening right now is they
are purposely destroying the dollar the
very thing they told you for the last 30
years you should save
and you should you should
you know trade your most valuable asset
for they are now destroying the very
thing that you've been saving
and they're penalizing you for having it
because they pay you nothing to keep it
understand that a thousand and i'm going
to answer your whole question here
understand that a thousand dollars today
at bank of america or wells fargo
let me see a thousand dollars today
times pays one dollar and twenty cents
let me see yeah that's one dollar and
twenty cent anyway
crazy okay now that's before you bought
your checks that's before you started
the the checking account that's before
you use the atm by the time the end of
the year is your thousand dollars
probably more like 920 bucks probably
cost you 80 bucks just to have a
checking account
so number one you become an investor
number two you get cash flow every
quarter number three i expect that
building to be a double or a triple so
i'm paying 260 for the building if i
sell it for 340 we make a double
i think the building is going to sell
for 500 million when i sell it
location's ridiculous can't replace it
it's 99 occupied right now it's a trophy
quality asset it's in fort lauderdale
florida one of the hottest markets in
the country and when i sell this
i will be selling it to an institution
and the reason that's important is
because most of us that are earning 50
bucks a night
you have to buy the leftovers man you
know the the we're buying leftovers
we're buying we're buying the garbage in
the community the duplex
the single family home
these are the same homes they went back
to the banks in 2010 and you don't want
to be in that stuff what you want to be
is the trophy stuff
that somebody always finds value in yeah
so i think the return is uh five to six
percent in the first year
paid out quarterly
uh we passed through the depreciation to
you so you won't be paying taxes for the
first couple of years on your income
um and i think you get a double or
triple
off your money so if you put in 10 grand
i think you're looking at your money
being 20 or 30 000 over the next five
six seven years habit number seven
develop self-confidence with dr ivan
joseph i use the definition of
self-confidence to be the ability or the
belief
to believe in yourself
to accomplish any task no matter the
odds no matter the difficulty no matter
the adversity the belief
that you can accomplish it
self-confidence the easiest way to build
self-confidence there's no magic button
i can't say hey this plane is going down
who can fly it put your hand up i can
i'm confident
[Laughter]
repetition repetition repetition
right what does malcolm gladwell call it
the ten thousand hour rule there's no
magic button i recruited a goalie from
columbia south america one year uh big
tall six foot three man
uh you know he had hands like stone i
thought he was like flipper every time i
throw him the ball dunk down onto the
ground i was like oh my god we're in
trouble
simple solution get to the wall kick a
ball against the wall and catch it kick
the ball against the wall and catch it
his goal was 350 a day for eight months
he came back
his hands were calloused the moisture on
his hands were literally gone he is now
playing in europe magic no repetition
repetition repetition
the problem is we expect to be
self-confident but we can't be unless
the skill or the task we're doing is not
novel is not new to us we want to be in
a situation where we've created we've
had so much pressure in that and what i
mean because pressure builds diamonds we
want to be in a situation where hey i've
done this a thousand times
i did my speech i practiced in front of
the mirror
hey i'm sounding good and then i read in
front of my kids and my men and my wife
i was like oh my gosh got a little
nervous then i get in front of the
glengool oh my goodness i'm a little
more nervous by the time i get to the
acg where 2500 people can't say anymore
right 2500 people
where 2500 people are there i won't have
a single ounce of nervousness because of
my ability to practice
right over and over and over again the
problem with repetition is
how many of us bail after the first bit
of failure how many of us fail after the
first bit of adversity edison was on
that video
and depends who you ask is anywhere from
one thousand to ten thousand tries to
build that light bulb
one thousand to ten thousand jk rowling
should be on that video the only
publisher she took her harry potter book
to
i believe the number was twelve or
thirteen i don't i'm pretty confident
but after two or three no's i'd be like
dang it after six or seven i'm like
maybe not definitely after nine or ten
i'd be looking to be a soccer coach or
something else beside an author
right i mean 12 times somebody said no
but
practice practice practice and do not
accept failure maybe it shouldn't be
repetition maybe the answer should be
persistence
because we all repeat something but very
few of us really will persist
so that's one way to build
self-confidence
get out there do what you want to do and
accept no do not accept no
the other one is self-talk we all have a
self-talk tape that plays in our head
anybody go shopping and put on a pair of
pants this week if you're a woman the
first thing that always comes damn i
look fat in these pants
and if you're a man it's the opposite oh
god i have no muscle i'm so flabby right
we all have this tape that plays in our
head as a student if they ask me the
question it was like oh gee please the
police professor don't pick me i don't
know the answer don't i look down we all
have this negative self-talk that goes
in our head
guess what
there's enough people that are telling
us we can't do it that we're not good
enough
why do we want to tell ourselves that
we know for a fact that thoughts
influence actions we saw it there with
the um with the video sheldon dr levy
showed right we know that our thoughts
influence actions why do we want to say
that negative self talk to ourselves
we need to get our own self-affirmations
muhammad ali what was his
self-affirmation
i am the greatest
who else is going to tell you there need
to be quiet moments in your bedroom
quiet moments when you're brushing your
teeth that we need to reaffirm
i am the captain of my ship and the
master of my fate
that is my affirmation
i came from a school of 1 000 people i
lived in a town of 1 000 people for 15
years there's no reason that i should be
in charge of an athletic department
building maple leaf gardens
but i am the captain of my ship and the
master of my fate
if i don't say it if i don't believe it
no one else will
how do you build self-confidence
get away from the people who will tear
you down
there's enough of that
muhammad ali
i am the greatest there is no one better
than me it's a difference between hubris
and ego
and false pride
it's just reminding yourself in quiet
silent moments i put it down on the list
it's right beside my mirror
right about all the things that make me
who i am because i make enough mistakes
and the newspapers will recognize it and
people around me will recognize it and
they'll tear me down
and pretty soon i'll begin to believe it
there was a time when my confidence was
really low
there was a time when i took this job
when i came from iowa
i don't know if i could do it
i had to bring out my self-confidence
letter
a letter i wrote to myself when i was
feeling good ivan congratulations on
getting your phd before 40.
congratu i am 40 under
congratulations on winning a national
championship good job on raising three
good kids and marrying the right woman i
wrote a letter to myself
it was my own brag sheet
my own letter about the things i was
proud of
because there are moments and we'll all
experience them in our career
in our life and our job hunting and our
relationships when we are not feeling
good about who and what and where we are
and i had to bring out that letter and
read it time and time again for a period
of about two weeks
to weather me through that storm
it was important
the self-talk the negative self-talk
habit number eight tame your social
media use with bailey parnell you see
i've worked in social marketing
primarily in higher education for most
of my career
that means i work with a lot of 18 to 24
year olds which also happens to be the
most active demographic on social media
the other thing you need to know about
me is that i'm young enough to have
grown up with social media
but just old enough to be able to
critically engage with it in a way that
12 year old me probably couldn't
so my life is social media personally
professionally and academically and if
it was doing this to me
what was it doing to everyone else
well i immediately found out i wasn't
alone
the center for collegiate mental health
found that the top three diagnoses on
university campuses
are anxiety depression and stress
and numerous studies from the us canada
the uk you name it have linked this high
social media use with these high levels
of anxiety and depression
but the scary thing is that high social
media use is almost everyone i know
it's my friends it's my family my
colleagues
90
of 18 to 29 year olds are on social
media
we spend on average two hours a day
there we don't even eat for two hours a
day
seventy percent of the canadian
population is on social media
our voter turnout isn't even 70
anything we do this often is worthy of
critical observation
anything we spend this much time doing
has lasting effects on us
so let me introduce you to four of the
most common stressors on social media
that if go unchecked have potential to
become full-blown mental health issues
and this is by no means an exhaustive
list
number one
the highlight reel
just like in sports the highlight reel
is a collection of the best and
brightest moments
social media is our personal highlight
reel it's where we put up our wins or
when we look great or when we're out
with friends and family
but we struggle with insecurity because
we compare our behind the scenes with
everyone else's highlight reels
we are constantly comparing ourselves to
others and yes this was happening before
social media with tv and celebrity but
now it's happening all the time and it's
directly linked to you
here's a perfect example i came across
in preparation for this talk it's my
friend on vacation brb nap
wait
why can't i afford vacation why am i
just sitting here in my pj's watching
netflix i want to be on a beach
but here's the thing i know her very
well i knew this was out of the ordinary
for her i knew she was typically
drowning in schoolwork but we think who
wants to see that
the highlights are what people want to
see
in fact when your highlights do well you
encounter the second stressor on social
media which is number two
social currency
just like the dollar a currency is
literally something we use to attribute
value to a good or service
in social media these likes the comments
the shares they've become this form of
social currency by which we attribute
value to something
in marketing we call it the economy of
attention
everything is competing for your
attention and when you give something
alike or a piece of that finite
attention it becomes a recorded
transaction attributing value
which is great if you're selling albums
or clothing
the problem is that in our social media
we are the product and we're letting
others attribute value to us
you know someone or are someone that's
taken down a photo because it didn't get
as many likes as you thought it would
and i'll admit i've been right there
with you
we took our product off the shelf
because it wasn't selling fast enough
this is changing our sense of identity
we are tying up our self-worth with what
others think about us and then we're
quantifying it for everyone to see
and we're obsessed we have to get that
selfie just right and we will take 300
photos to make sure
and then we'll wait for the perfect time
to post
we're so obsessed we have biological
responses when we can't participate
which leads me to the third stressor on
social media number three
fomo
it's a light phrase we all throw it
around
but fomo or the fear of missing out is
an actual social anxiety from the fear
that you are missing a potential
connection event or opportunity a
collection of canadian universities
found that seven out of ten students
said they would get rid of their social
networking accounts if it were not for
fear of being left out of the loop out
of curiosity how many people here have
or have considered deactivating your
social
wow that's almost everyone
that fomo you feel the highlight reels
the social currency
those are all results of a relatively
quote-unquote normal social media
experience
but what if going on social every day
was a terrifying experience where you
not just questioned your self-worth but
you questioned your safety
perhaps the worst stressor on social
media is number four online harassment
40 percent of online adults have
experienced online harassment
73 percent have witnessed it
and the unfortunate reality is that it
is much worse and much more likely if
you're a woman lgbtq person of color
muslim i think you get the point
the problem is that in the news we're
seeing these big stories
we're seeing the 18 year old tyler
clemente who took his life after his
roommate secretly filmed him kissing
another guy and outed him on twitter
we see women like anita sarkeesian being
close to shamed off the internet and
sent death and rape threats for sharing
their feminism we see these stories once
it's too late
but what about the everyday online
harassment what about that ugly snapchat
you sent your friend with the intention
of it being private and now it's up on
facebook and so it's just one photo it's
funny it's just one mean comment it's
not a big deal
but when these micro moments happen over
and over again over time
that's when we have a macro problem
we have to recognize these everyday
instances as well because if they go
unchecked and the effects unnoticed we
are going to have many more tyler
clementi's
the effects aren't always easy to
recognize how many of you have noticed
the notifications at the top of my
screen
yeah and how many of you like me are
bothered that they're not checked
yeah okay here let me check them for you
okay
just one small example of what this can
do to you maybe you simply cannot focus
because your notifications are going off
the handle and you need to check
that need
eventually becomes addiction
regarding social media we are already
experiencing impairments similar to
substance dependencies with every like
you get a shot of that feel-good
chemical dopamine
you gain more of that social currency so
what do we do to feel good we check
likes just one more time
we post
just one more time
we're anxious
if we don't have access
does not sound like every drug you've
ever heard of
yeah
so when that grows when your social
media use goes unconfronted over time
that's when we see the rising levels of
anxiety and depression the fomo the
distractions the highlight reels the
comparisons it's a lot and it's all the
time
the canadian association of mental
health found that as young as grades 7
to 12 students who spent 2 hours a day
on social media reported higher levels
of anxiety depression and suicidal
thoughts
for those of you doing the math that's
as young as 12 years old
now here's the thing
i like social media i do i love it
and hearing what i've said today might
make you think i want you to get off of
it but i don't you see i don't think
it's going anywhere so i'm not going to
waste my time telling you to spend less
time on social media frankly i don't
think abstinence is an option anymore
but that doesn't mean you can't practice
safe social
you see everything i've talked about
today has nothing
and everything to do with social media
what do i mean i mean social media is
neither good nor bad it's just the most
recent tool we're using to do we've
always done tell stories and communicate
with each other
you wouldn't blame samsung television
for a bad tv show
twitter doesn't make people write
hateful posts
so when we talk about this dark side of
social media what we're really talking
about is the dark side of people that
dark side that makes harassers harass
that insecurity that makes you take down
a photo you were excited to share that
dark side that looks at a picture of a
happy family and wonders why yours
doesn't look like that
so as parents as educators as friends as
bosses this dark side is what we need to
focus on
we need preventative strategies and
coping strategies so that when you have
your low days because you will when
you're questioning your self-worth you
never get as low as tyler clementi
then the many others like him
okay bailey how do you find social media
wellness
here's the good news the good news is
that recognizing a problem is the first
step to fixing it so hearing this talk
is just that step one recognize the
problem do you know the power of
suggestion when someone tells you about
something and then you start seeing it
everywhere
that's why awareness is critical because
now you will at least be better able to
recognize these effects if and when they
happen to you
the second thing you're going to do is
audit your social media diet
the same way we monitor what goes into
our mouth monitor what goes into your
head and heart
ask yourself did that facebook scroll
make me feel better or worse off
how many times do i actually check likes
why am i responding this way to that
photo
and then ask yourself if you're happy
with the results and you might be and
that's okay
but if you're not move on to step three
create a better online experience
after my partner did his audit he
realized his self-worth was too tied up
in social media but particularly
celebrities reminding him of the things
he didn't have
so he unfollowed all brands and all
celebrities and that worked for him but
it might not be celebrities for you for
me i had to purge other people off my
timeline so let me tell you a secret you
do not have to follow your friends
the truth is that sometimes our friends
or the people we have on facebook as a
courtesy
they just suck online you find yourself
in the middle of this passive aggressive
status war you didn't even know is
happening or you're looking at 50 photos
of the same concert from the same angle
if you want to follow artists or
comedians or cats you can do that
the last thing you're going to do is
model good behavior
offline we're taught not to bully other
kids in the playground we're taught to
respect others and treat them how they
deserve to be treated we're taught not
to kick others when they're down or take
pleasure in their downfalls
social media is a tool
and it's a tool that can be used for
good for more positive groups for
revolutions for putting grumpy cat in
disney movies
tell you the internet is a weird place
so is social media hurting your mental
health the answer is it does not have to
social can tear you down yes
or it can lift you up where you leave
feeling better off or have an actual
laugh out loud
if i only have 24 hours in the day if
i'm gonna spend two of those hours on
social media then i prefer my
experiences to be full of inspiration
laughs motivation and a whole lot of
grumpy cat in disney movies happy number
nine have a morning routine with jay
shetty every weekday i wake up at 6 00
a.m i haven't set an alarm for a long
time but i know that my body will
naturally wake me up based on the
routine that i've created
i usually sleep for about eight hours a
night and i'm very grateful to have that
much time and i prioritize sleeping at
about 10 p.m every single day when i'm
up the first thing my mind wants to do
is say something like i feel so tired
i've got so much to do today
and i as soon as i wake up in that
moment rewire and reprogram it to say i
am happy i am healthy and i am healing
that simple internal affirmation and
statement rewires how i feel about what
i have that day i'm grateful for the
opportunities in the work i have i'm
healing with the challenges i have and
my body is healthy because i'm able to
get out of bed i don't look at my phone
in the morning trust me i don't always
follow this i've broken that rule many
many times i'm not perfect i've failed
at it countless times but i keep trying
to rise back to this rule why because i
feel amazing the amount of clarity in my
mind the stillness that i experience
when my phone isn't the first thing that
i see
is
inconceivable and i highly recommend
that you try it out just for seven days
don't look at your phone first thing in
the morning and see how different you
feel for the rest of the day i promise
you you're going to feel more energetic
more productive and more creative than
you've ever been before now i've been
practicing something for a long time now
called mindful brushing i brush each
tooth for around four seconds before i
move the toothbrush this mindful process
allows me to start the day at my own
time in my own pace so often before i
used to rush brushing my teeth
not only would i be damaging my gums and
damaging my teeth by the way dentists
will tell you about that i actually was
starting my day off in a panic with
stress
slowing down the first activity of the
day
allows you to start and move at your own
pace in your own time
the next thing i do after a shower is
meditate meditation has been a part of
my daily practice for the last 16 years
where i've meditated for at least two
hours a day often this is broken up
throughout the days on a busy day on an
amazing day i get to do two hours first
thing in the morning sometimes i'll do
one hour in the morning one hour in the
evening or sometimes i'll do 30 minute
slots four times a day this really
allows me to find that center to find
that alignment and find that balance
throughout the day my meditation
practice includes three types of
meditation
visualization and mantra for those of
you that have read think like a monk you
know that i break down these practices
inside the book so that you can practice
them at home as well breath work is a
phenomenal way of calming and centering
my body visualization is a great way to
prepare my mind for all the meetings and
events and everything i have to do
throughout the day
and the mantra is for my soul it's to
help me feel connected to my purpose
make me feel connected to divine energy
and the supreme source so that i can be
an instrument of that joy of that
happiness and of that love in the world
with everyone i mean recently i've
updated my morning meditation using the
aura ring app where i take a moment to
check my body status what this does is
that it helps me measure my heart rate
my breath rate and my skin temperature
just for a moment just to take a status
check just to check in with myself and
say how am i feeling how am i doing
right now it even asks me if i'm feeling
better or worse after the moment and
that allows me to get that really
critical piece of insight into how i
feel right now when you bump into
someone you always ask them how are you
doing how are you feeling
take a moment to ask yourself that with
the moments feature on the aura ring app
after my meditation practice i literally
take two to three minutes to set my
intention for the day and my attention
for the day
i found that this activity allows me to
create the energy and the mental space i
need to try and live by higher values
now again i fail at this all the time i
can go through the day and then realize
i haven't been loving i haven't been
kind i haven't been the nicest person
that day but the thing is when i write
it down in the morning i promise you i'm
more likely to be what i write on the
page i'm reminded to be what i write on
the page i also take a moment to write
three things i'm grateful for
and no matter how hard it is they're at
prom i promise you there are some days
where i'm like i've just got complaints
i've got nothing to be grateful for and
even on those days i will push myself to
write down something i'm grateful for
and i'll always find an answer
starting your day off in this way gets
this right so that now every action can
actually be inspired by that intention
everything that you do externally will
be created by how you feel internally
and now you can take that energy out
into the world we are headed to morning
tennis so this is something that i do
around
four times a week
i realized that i just missed playing
sport when i'd wake up in the morning
and i'd head over to the gym or with the
trainer i always found that slightly
stressful the idea of just being there
with one person and
trying to do a bunch of exercises that
were meaningless or purposeless at least
to me
but going to play it's just incredible
to play tennis every morning i feel like
i'm back at school and i'm starting my
day with some great energy some
positivity a little bit of healthy
competition
so for the past three to four months
i've been wearing the aura ring
and it's been
amazing to have it on truly because for
the first time i can actually verify
what i'm doing
how
powerful and impactful it is on my
physical and mental health
and i can actually track record and look
back
and plan
and i realized this because there's so
much thought in business and in
technology all around how you can't
improve what you don't measure and the
truth is we never measure our sleep we
kind of take a guess i've been getting
around six hours or seven hours of sleep
this week it's a guess it's random it's
made up you're hoping you kind of got it
right you're like oh yeah but last week
i
i worked out a lot
and you don't know it's just an
assumption it's just an idea whereas now
i can actually look back i can look at
how the week's been i can understand why
i feel tired i can understand what i
need to do this weekend play has become
such an important value to me there's a
beautiful quote that i believe was said
by richard branson where he said that
we don't stop playing because we get old
we get old because we stopped playing
and i realized that play was such an
important value for me it was such an
important principle for me that i had to
start my day off with play a bit of
healthy competition feeling like i'm
learning a new skill feeling like i'm
building a new athletic ability allows
me to start the day off feeling like a
learner and someone who's growing so
usually after game of tennis i sit down
to look at my stats it's a great way of
keeping that measurement thinking about
what's coming ahead for the rest of the
day and i can see that it's
automatically detected that i've had a
506 active calorie burn i've got an
activity score of 79. i've got a total
burn of 2357 calories and i've already
done 4 000 steps for the day so i love
starting my day off with that data it
helps me feel like i've started on the
right foot and now i know what i've got
to do to hit my goals it's also told me
that my training volume is optimal my
training frequency is optimal as well
and i've got to still stay active today
because i'm still in the red so that's
telling me that i need to move around
regularly and avoid long periods of
inactivity which helps me stay healthy
and keep my metabolism high
this is a great reminder because
throughout the day it will keep
reminding me the active whether i'm
sitting at my desk for too long or
whether i'm sitting there writing
scripts it will tell me to get up and
move around and until my activity
reaches optimal i'll know that i still
gotta keep moving
as soon as i get back from tennis i have
some breakfast my current breakfast of
choice is a chia seed breakfast bowl it
has blueberries and raspberries inside
as well and it's been amazing for my gut
health i find that figuring out the food
that's right for your gut is so
important and it's so personal and
unique it's taken me a long time to
figure out what to have for breakfast
that didn't leave me feeling bloated
didn't feel me leaving uncomfortable
throughout the rest of the day and a
chia seed breakfast bowl has been the
best thing that i've had as i'm coming
to the end of breakfast that's usually
when i look at my stats from the night
before i look at the quality of my sleep
the quality of my rem sleep my deep
sleep i look at what i need to do today
and what i love about the auraing app is
that it guides me and coaches me
throughout my day it will tell me what
time i should aim to be asleep it will
tell me what to avoid it will even tell
me to stay active for me it's really
useful having this guide in my pocket
and helping me make my choices
throughout the day and then i sit down
for my favorite cup of herbal tea
usually it's a fresh mint and for me
having a warm cup of herbal tea allows
me to again start grounded i love the
scent
i love the feeling of the warmth inside
of my body and i love the cleansing
effect that it has and so this is where
i am now all of these habits have had a
huge impact on my life and that's why
i'm sharing them with you and habit
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus clips is set a timeline
with alex ortner what are some
fundamental must-haves you feel like
for that evening wind down or or evening
routine
um
i mean for me for starters uh it is
actually setting timelines on the things
and the way you shut yourself down or
slow yourself down from the day and i've
got the same structure for my kids and
then a lot of myself evolves around my
kids so i know that for my kids now it's
eight o'clock all devices are off and
that includes adults um all of us
devices are off at eight o'clock eight
o'clock to nine o'clock it's that
getting ready for bed it's spending time
together it's like calming our body down
so that we can get ready for bed right
and just being present with each other
and talking about the day and all that
kind of stuff because family for me is
everything and that's you know for me
the happiest part of my day is you know
i can have a great day but at the end of
the day i get to the end of the day and
my kids have something tough going on
i'm like okay what can i what can i do
to help them and support them so it is
that wind down process of shutting off
from devices
and then just like i do in the morning
process it's
being present with myself and i notice
the difference you know i'm not perfect
about doing my planner all the time
sometimes i'll miss a morning or missing
evening and when i don't
i'm basically just not just like i said
in the example during this i'm not being
that pilot i'm being that pilot who just
runs on the plane and starts flying
without going through my checklist
process to make sure that i'm actually
going where i want to go and doing what
i want to do and so i make sure to be
present with myself emotionally and go
what am i actually feeling from today
what do i need to release um you know
whether it's anger or frustration not
really i don't really get angry anymore
i used to be angry as a teenager a good
amount uh but i don't get angers is not
an emotion that i really dive into
frustration definitely would be
um but i i recognize what emotions i
have and i will and i tap to release
them
right i tap to i acknowledge them and i
release them so that i can actually get
myself to bed and i always just go back
to acknowledging that i'm doing my best
right that we're all doing our best that
you know no matter how much i you know
want to beat myself up or think i could
have done better or i should be further
along i mean that's a common theme for
everybody is oh i should be further
along in my life or my business or
further along with my health and i just
acknowledge and go hey i'm doing my best
and the more i beat myself up about that
the more i rob my joy of being present
with life
at the end of the day what happens to me
what matters to me is my health like man
i just when i can get a good run in or
play soccer that is the most alive i
feel in any given day and then just
being present with people and i and i
have to always remind myself being
present with people because i'm always
around people the question is am i
actually present with them in a way
where i can enjoy those interactions and
so i just remind myself of those things
i always i do gratitude every evening i
i write down three things that i'm
grateful for in the evening i think
that's a really important process i
notice in my planner literally the
second i get to that part and i go i
start tapping into gratitude my whole
body just goes
and it just calms me down and i go oh
yeah there's always so much to be
grateful for every single day so i go
through that process so those are just
some of the things i do in the evening
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
the seven genius habits that will change
your life this year check the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there you know for seven days track
your latte factor oprah when i did the
one of the oprah shows she we showed the
latte factor and she pulled off a cloth
and showed this woman's lattice factory
and we had a quarter of a million
dollars in cash